we are both from Texas I know do you
miss it I do I miss the Tex-Mex that's
what I missed I miss a Tex-Mex
um but I'm moving home I'm moving back
to San Antonio oh you are yeah oh I love
San Antonio yeah but you're from I'm
from Fort Worth yeah you're from the
north yes it is it is different but I
love I love San Antonio it's a great
City it's they did such a great job like
just it's an easy City to walk around
like I don't see a lot of places in
Texas it's a driving Place yeah okay
like but in San Antonio I feel like I
could walk everywhere it's like Austin
you can walk a lot of places it's also I
mean the best Tex-Mex is in San Antonio
and and South
um but or in Fort Worth whatever
[Applause]
I love it I just love the runny queso
that's what people don't get yeah it's
the melted queso the melted cheese
versus the runny queso yeah I have no
time for any queso that's not runny I
know a lot of cheese and Tex-Mex yeah
now I live part-time in Mexico City now
oh I love Mexico as well yeah Mexico
City and the food is obviously yeah very
different and my husband's Mexican and
I'm Texican and so we fight all the time
like he's like I had so much cheese I'm
like yes exactly join me won't you yeah
right it's so good hence the reason it's
so good no I do like authentic Mexican
food yeah yeah there's it's amazing the
the diversity in Mexico food yeah yeah
um why so you're there often you're in
Mexico yeah like half the time we're
half Mexico City half Los Angeles that's
awesome now we're going to be Mexico
City San Antonio
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
guys I'm going home